chris yeah carl today we are playing
fall guys
finally yes here's what we're gonna do
carl
yes carl pick someone in need oh my
sister's having a wedding chris
pick someone in need my mom has debt
carl if you finish in first place on
fall guys i'll put
twenty thousand dollars towards your
sister's wedding oh my god geez that's a
lot
and chris if you come in first place
i'll put twenty thousand dollars towards
your mom's debt thank you
and if i come in first place i'll buy
twenty thousand dollars worth of food
and give it away so it's a win-win no
matter what
okay ready up i'm a legend at this game
hey call your sister before we start
chris call your mom and the first
challenge is this obstacle of course i'm
really good at this one
i'm filming right now the cameras are
rolling i'm playing a video game
and i'm trying to win 20 grand for you
oh don't curse
i can't say that it's family friendly
points off because it's cursing all
right corey i'm winning it for you i
gotta go though guys we gotta focus
this fan won't stop beating me dude i
don't think jimmy knows how to play
i don't think jimmy's playing much how
do i dive uh square
x x sorry i play playstation i'm not a
noob i play on the xbox original hyper
can do controller
nope oh i went for the risky play and it
was not worth it
uh oh carl's gonna get on top
your sister seemed happy you might pay
off a wedding yeah no kidding
i think anybody would be it'd be a shame
if you didn't okay i'm not gonna lie
she's been mad at me lately for not
calling her but it's because i've been
playing this game
so now she has no excuse to be mad at me
so who is that is that chris
who's this pirate
you are like the 40th person yeah you
got to play risky man
no you don't no wait it's for my mom
never mind you don't gotta play rescue
chris's mom watching is like sweating
she's like stop playing risky as you
guys all know
the first challenge in fall guys is
pretty easy we all survived oh this is
the pictionary one let's work together
nobody say the fruits out loud guys i
just want to remind you
that if you win you get 20 000 thank you
for reminding us
yeah 20 grand on the line all right
grapes grapes i'm all right i'm going to
say it aloud
i'm on grapes grape apple grape apple
grape apple so
grape come with me stay here don't move
oh that guy got risky
is there a cherry apple i got cherry
over here great plate right here
all right is this a great buy soon okay
i'm gonna be honest this one's a little
bit easy just follow where everybody is
yeah
yeah okay okay apple banana i got apple
banana grape okay yeah i got cherry i'm
standing on cherry and orange cherry
orange cherry orange i'm gonna stand on
a banana cherry orange i got banana
watermelon apple's up top left top left
baby where is that right here right here
push the glitter push the clip oh my god
all right oh my god we qualified guys
high five no content hey hey it's a
little early to be high-fiving boys
chris there might come a time where you
have to stomp on carl to win i
i'm not gonna try and beat him carl so
you're saying carl's sister's wedding's
more important than your mom's death
i need to just focus on doing my best
and not worrying about carl i'm gonna be
real
all right jimmy hey i'm also gonna be
real i've never played this one before
i've
never played this okay don't once you
get onto the convertible do not jump do
not jump at all
unless you absolutely have to i i'm in
the back i'm in the oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my god just don't jump
just do not jump why it's not worth
because on the conveyor belt you'll just
fall backwards
oh my gosh it's like a nuclear war zone
oh i don't understand why would it why
would it why would you not
jump no do not jump dude i got top three
without jumping why would you not jump
over the logs
top oh yeah jump over the logs why yeah
jump over the lawns well i just not
stopped because you guys told me not to
no we're saying don't spam jump don't
spam
jump up oh jimmy done oh no isn't he
dude i listen to my videos
wow no that was coral that was coral
that's what happens when you listen here
i guess we just don't care about food
banks all right i'm gonna come spy
hey boys hi okay everybody shut up it's
block party track get to the middle get
to the middle
stop it i'm gonna kill grabbers all my
homies hate people that grab
you let the grabbers know that you're
trying to pay for your sister's wedding
i didn't mean to grab you i didn't mean
to grab you i it cued the grab bro you
know it
this is for mama guys comment down below
would you rather pay off chris's mom's
debt or pay for carl's sister's wedding
oh come on
mama took care of me so now oh i oh
my gosh oh you did not see me get stuck
you were stuck
chris you okay you're out now please
root for me oh it's the gauntlet though
wish me luck
please root for me it's the gauntlet as
long as he doesn't win
wait what's wrong with me winning and i
qualified baby
i'm sad see that gamer muscle right
there oh tiptoe this is where carl
may get screwed over oh here we go here
we go carl don't die here don't sit
right here
focus if you die here focus
yeah one more
it's top seven if this is hexagon i
think this video is ending quick
it's now you versus six other people
jump showdown i thought we'd have to
play a bunch of rounds but carl might
win the first one
oh there's two of them bro thank god i
jumped from it holy cow i'm fading
oh i'm insane
oh i got so cocky all right we're going
in
baby all right we are going i'm getting
it with 20 000
on the line boys i got this hey camera
zoom in on my face this is serious are
we on back row
oh no i'm front row yeah back row baby
oh got pushed off by a pigeon that also
don't i fell
that was all me open up open up open up
hey hey
i'm in the front oh god all right i'm
just gonna run through and just pray
jesus loves me oh jesus does love me
i didn't stop i didn't stop running
top ten easy dove top ten top ten
top ten chris where are you ah in
in in erode the glizzy slime
climb oh baby jimmy get ready to
spectate i'm gonna take it slower than
usual i'm not gonna lie
guys try to keep up i want to die oh god
i got pushed
i
let's do this partner let's do this
jimmy this next part is really hard and
you might get tilted but just know i
love you
chris go go ugh grass i didn't do it
that's not on me
you breathed i'm sorry for breathing get
out the way orange
no wait you're eliminated if you fall
there yeah dude
yeah man it's just over what eliminate
the glitzy eliminate the collision oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah got a day eliminated you're just
sitting at the end trying to screw
people
chris i love how you have twenty
thousand dollars to lose and they have
nothing to lose yet you mess with them
i qualified i qualified right at the end
and he died
yeah i don't care
full both yo we need to strap hey corey
hello
uh well actually i'm jimmy what do you
want to say to cheer carl on
he's competing for you if you're not
gonna win i'm not gonna get married
i just got my marriage license in the
mail today it's all on this
oh no better get better at soccer carl
oh i saved it but i fell in the goal go
through the goal go to the goal i got
mid i got made i got mid i got mid i got
mid oh my god do you see that goal
yeah are you adding any value to the
team i'm goalie when i
i only do stuff when it comes back here
but since all midfield ain't nothing
going back there we scored another goal
oh i need you to pay attention carl went
right past because i have to you might
not care about your sister's wedding
staying made if you knew anything about
this video
made you idiot it went to you
that's another goal yeah
almost double digits almost all right
let's quit out there's six people left
but you both are part of it jump
showdown oh hey
hey carl this is what you just lost 20
grand on not lost yet
just delayed here we go here we go
oh mine was the first to go oh
chris i'm baiting on bait number eight
number three
don't make it it's not worth it it's not
worth it one eliminated
guys the numbers are dwindling i'm
actually petrified no more talking guys
chris christopher oh chris crass
oh oh did it flip
oh my jump button didn't work when i
pressed it it's down to the wire my jump
button's not working very fast
some reason two platforms left oh this
is so close two platforms left
five people remain oh i hate this it's
getting so fast it's going faster and
faster
oh it's us and one other person guys
chris if you grab
hey are we agreeing to not grab to we're
agreeing
guys you two and then one other person
oh
he's not moved in 30 minutes
how is he just jumping he hasn't moved
how is he just jumping he's just about
to jump his own there he goes
oh wait oh he recovered that's his
covered holy cow it's like double speed
yeah
it's going fast five
oh now it's you two versus each other oh
my gosh gonna win
oh my gosh it's ending here who's gonna
win chris
or carl no
i rag dog i couldn't get up no chris i'm
sorry
my car just won twenty thousand dollars
what if i to tell you i'm calling with
twenty thousand dollars
towards you i don't know i believe
are you serious dead serious he
literally won it's actually his first
time ever winning on the gaming channel
that's why i don't believe it
uh corey can chris come to your wedding